[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
today's question comes from Adrienne in
Georgia Adrien writes my fiance and I
are in our 70s a girl Adrien I love it
and planning on marrying in the next six
months dude yes we're going to we're
going to end up at the end with no tread
left on the tires good for you I've
heard your advice on always combining
finances as a married couple however I'm
not sure if that's a reasonable path
when both parties have children from
previous marriages what's the best
approach here that's a great question
that is a great question yes yeah
because you know there yes you guys as a
as an entity as a married couple you're
going to be dealing with finances
together you're going to be doing paying
household bills like working as a team
on all of that but it always raises an
interesting point when there are grown
children involved from previous families
and you know do you suddenly combine the
family just because you got married in
your 70s and everyone's equal all of you
know what I mean like all of that and
yeah and I lean towards keeping it
separate still at this at this stage of
life I mean in my head I'm like like
you're you're you're you're immediate
family before this marriage was pretty
much done I mean like you grown kids
you've done your job You' made your life
this is something different that's right
exactly this is somebody like let's just
are we going to let's just party until
the wheels fall off like let's do this
together I love that right so I'm all
about combining your incomes at this
point seeing yourselves as one cuz you
guys could still have 20 great years so
as much as a team aspect that you can do
sh I mean all my advice would be the
same but I would say things like estate
planning Wills stuff with grown kids if
you want to keep all of that more
separate and his money that he brought
into the marriage maybe is is divvied up
among his kid I don't know like well
this is one of the very few times and
again this this matters a lot if they
neither of them have anything it doesn't
matter right right right um but if
either of you or both of you have any
sort of um wealth or an estate this is
one of the rare times when I would be
okay not only okay but I would recommend
a prenup and here's why you're not
protecting each
other you're protecting the your husband
or wife if one of you passes away from
cousins and kids coming out of the woods
that is going to take stuff from you so
it might be that I don't don't
want if um Rachel if you and I were
married and I died I don't want my kids
suing you like I don't want that mess so
I want both sides be protected here but
I do think for the sake of your marriage
whatever money Social Security coming
here dividends coming here I think they
should go in the same pot and we're
going to make married decisions about
bills we're not just going to be
roommates for the next 20 years we're
going to be married so let's do it let's
let's do it right absolutely yeah and
that's not just from the technical
aspect and the logistic side of it but
there's also an emotional part of this I
mean andreen like when you really do see
yourself as one and this is if you're 70
and getting married or 27 and getting
married there's an emotional connection
there that's really beautiful and I
don't want you guys missing out on that
even for the 20 years maybe you guys
have together um in the in the you know
vein of like well we're just adults now
and we you know we've done this all
ourselves so we're going to just keep it
separate I think you guys miss a level
of intimacy and connection if you don't
combine what yes the income that coming
in now or Social Security all of that
like your your life livelihood and your
um day-to-day life combine all of that
financially and work as a team and just
for just just for like a different
picture of this um my wife and I have
been married for 21
years it feels like a thousand years
we've been married both good and bad
there's a chance they are married that
long or or maybe a little bit long right
that's a long time yes so let's do this
let's do it let's we're married we're
going to be married we're going to be
all in both feet in the boat we're not
just going to have one foot on land and
one foot in the water it's good create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life